GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE MAY THIRTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE. BEFORE YOU. DO EVEN
CALL THE ROLL THIS OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEE NOW OKAY. SO WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE'RE
GONNA START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
OF MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ARE
MONITORING THIS HEARING FROM
THEIR OFFICES PLEASE COME TO
ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN SO THAT
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM. TO
START I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE STAFF THAT HAVE MADE OUR
RETURN TO THE CAPITAL TO HEAR
BILLS POSSIBLE. TO DO THAT MY
WIFE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ALL THE STAFF. FOR MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR ME TO LEAVE. DUE
TO THE CURRENT STATE HOME
MORTAR WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON.
CONSISTENT WITH THE CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE OF THE HOUSE THAT
PEOPLE PARTICIPATING COMMITTEE
HEARINGS MUST BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED. WE ARE REQUIRING THAT
ALL THOSE ATTENDING THIS
HEARING IN PERSON MUST WEAR A
MASK. WITH A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WHEN THIS TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HEARING OR FOR THIRTY SEVEN OF
THE STATE CAPITOL WE'RE HAVING
A PHYSICALLY. AND IN PERSON
HEARING. SPACE WE CAN ONLY
COMMON SEVEN COMMITTEE. AND
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF.
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIXTY THE SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL. PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLICNOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM. WE
HAVE SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING
USE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS. WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONY LIVE AND ALSO
ASK QUESTIONS OF THESE
WITNESSES. THERE MAY BE A
SLIGHT DELAY FOR THE STREAM
FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM SO PLEASE BE
PATIENT. WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE PUBLIC
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AN
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
OR COMPUTER SCREEN. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DIAL
IN AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN Q. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU WERE CALLING
IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MOOD MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST THE
BILL YOU WILL REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE IT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
FOUR AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
THAT TRY TO HELP. I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION THROUGH
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS. WE ALL
FACE. A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS BEFORE YOU MOVED
TO THE BILLS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
AGENDA OF A FEW ADDITIONAL
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENTS TO
MAKE. FIRST I HAVE A LETTER
FROM THE SPEAKER APPOINTING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES ROSS TO
THE COMMITTEE IN PLACE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IAN CALDERON FOR THE
PURPOSES OF TODAY'S HEARING
ONLY THIS ONE MEMBER ALMOST
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. THAT
ARE HEARING TODAY. SECOND I
HAVE A LETTER FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK. REQUESTING THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN BE
PERMITTED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR HUNDRED. ON HIS BEHALF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN THANKS
FOR ASSISTANCE WHEN YOU GET
HERE I SAW A MEMBER MULLIN.
PAGING ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN.
A CELL NUMBER QUIRK WILL ALSO
BE JOINING US BY TELEPHONE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PRESENTATION
OF HIS BILL. A THIRD OF THE
COMMITTEE'S RULES GENERALLY
PROVIDE FOR BILLS. IS A SEVEN
MEMBER MAYES FOR BILLS TO BE
HEARD IN AUTHOR SIGN IN ORDER
IN LIGHT OF THE LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES WITH CONDUCTING
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN A MANNER
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
NEED FOR PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
HOWEVER ALL COMMITTEES HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO HEAR BILLS AND
FILE ORDER. CERTAINLY WILL BE
HEARING BILLS AND FILE ORDER
TODAY. THIS CHANGE IN OUR USUAL
PROCEDURES IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S RULES WHICH
PERMIT BILLS TO BE TAKEN UP AND
ANOTHER ORDER IF THE CHAIR
FINDS IT TO BE MORE EXPEDIENT.
FINALLY THERE ARE TWO BILLS ON
THE COMMITTEES FOR BOTH CONSENT
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WILL BE TAKING OF THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AFTER THE
FIRST BILL IS PRESENTED BEFORE
I GET ON TO THE NEXT COUPLE OF
PAGES OF THIS LET'S STOP TO
TAKING ROLE- MISTER SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN HERE. BERMAN HERE.
GALLAGHER HERE. GALLAGHER HERE.
RAMOS THERE. RAMOS HERE LOW MAY
EIGHTH HERE MAYES HERE MULLIN
WEBER. GREAT TO HAVE A QUORUM
GOING BACK TO THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS- BILL
PRESENTATIONS WITH ALL THOSE
ANNOUNCEMENTS OUT OF THE WAY WE
WILL NOW I'M PERFECT TIMING
MOVE ON TO THE BILLS ON THE
COMMITTEE'S AGENDA THE FIRST
BILL TO BE PRESENTED IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS- WELL AS A NUMBER ALMOST
MAKES HIS WAY TO THE TABLE TO
PRESENT HIS BILL IF THERE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WERE
INTERESTED IN SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF. OR IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE CALL AND NOW
AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN A SOME NUMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY YOU
MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
TODAY I'M PRESENTING- AB TWENTY
THREE FOURTEEN AND THIS BILL
AIMS TO INCREASE NATIVE
AMERICAN VOTER ACCESSIBILITY TO
THE ELECTORAL PROCESS BY
ESTABLISHING A NATIVE AMERICAN
VOTING A SENSIBILITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. TO BE FORMED TO BE
FORMED BY THE SECRETARY OF
STATE YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. LIKE OTHER
DISENFRANCHISED ETHNIC GROUPS
IN THE UNITED STATES THE
HISTORY A NATIVE AMERICANS.
VOTING AND THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACCESSIBILITY TO THOSE RIGHTS
IS SHAMEFUL AND A HORDE PAST OF
THE HISTORY. NOT ONLY IN THE
NATION BUT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ACCORDING TO
THE NATIVE AMERICAN VOTING
RIGHTS COALITION. WHEN THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT WAS PASSED
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY SIX. MAKING
ALL PERSONS BORN IN THE UNITED
STATES CITIZENS. INDIANS ON
RESERVATIONS WERE SPECIFICALLY
EXCLUDED. RIGHTS OF CITIZENSHIP
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS COULD NOT
BE. EXERCISE WITHOUT RENOUNCING
THEIR TRIBAL MEMBERSHIP IT
WASN'T UNTIL NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR WITH THE PASSAGE OF THE
SNYDER ACT YET EVEN THEN VOTER
SUPPRESSION TACTICS SUCH AS
THOSE PRACTICE AGAINST OTHER
ETHNIC GROUP ETHNIC GROUPS WAS
EMPLOYED. IN LIGHT OF THE
CURRENT COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS.
THIS BILL IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ARE A GREAT HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC RISKS DUE TO THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC IN AS NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ACROSS OUR
STATE NAVIGATE THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FOLLOWING THIS
CRISIS. LIFTING NATIVE AMERICAN
VOICES WILL BE VITAL TO
ENSURING THE EQUITABLE.
RELATIONSHIP IN RECOVERY DURING
THIS TIME JOINING ME TODAY IS
ROBERT APPLETON FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE IN
CAROLINE BILL HUNTER ON THE
PHONE ON BEHALF OF THE SHE DID
HE WENT TO THE- NATION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE
TO- HAVE ROBERT APPLETON BE
ABLE TO PRESENT THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER RAMOS- AND AS A REMINDER
EACH PRIMARY WITNESS HAS UP TO
THREE MINUTES TO TESTIFY. YOU
ARE ENCOURAGED HOWEVER TO KEEP
YOUR MARCH BRIEF AND REFRAIN
FROM TESTIMONY THAT IS
DUPLICATIVE OF TESTIMONY FROM
OTHER WITNESSES. LET'S GO TO
OUR FIRST PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THE FIRST
ONE IS THE ROBERT AVALON FROM
THE OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF
STATE- EXPEDIA. WHO IS HERE IN
THE ROOM MISTER AVALON YOU MAY
PROCEED RIGHT- GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AND
THANK YOU WRESTLING AROMAS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
I AM ROBBIE AVALON FOR DEBBIE
SECRETARY STATE FOR POLICY AND
PLANNING HERE ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE HOW EXPEDIA
UNDER PROBABLY SPONSORING AB
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN TO
FORMALLY CODIFIED INTO LAW THE
CREATION OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN
VOTE EXCESSIVE BUILT. IN EVERY
COUNTRY. THEIR UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. AND FOR ACCESS THE
BALLOT AND UNIQUE CHALLENGES
AND BERRIES BARRIERS TO ACCESS
TO REGISTRATION. THEIR STATES
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATIONS
FACES. THIS COMMITTEE WILL
BRING TO LIGHT THESE CHALLENGES
THAT THIS COMMUNITY FACES I
WILL RIDE DISCUSSION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR ELECTION
EQUITY FOR NATIVE AMERICANS
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR STATE
ELECTIONS. THE NATIVE AMERICAN
VOTING ACCESSIBILITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WILL HELP GUIDE OUR
OUR REACH OUR MESSAGING AND OUR
POLICIES IN REGARDS TO
ELECTIONS AND EQUITY THANK.
THANK YOU- MISTER AVALON AT THE
SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS CAROLINE
VEAL HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE
ALL FIVE D. HE WENT TO NATION.
WHO'S ON THE PHONE LINE. ISRAEL
HUNTER YOU MAY PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CAROLINE BILL COMES FROM BEHALF
OF THE TODAY HE WENT TO NATION
AND I AM PLEASED TO JOIN. STATE
OFFICE IN THE FORTY EIGHTY. AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY GOAL TO
INCREASE NATIVE AMERICAN VOTER
ABILITY ELECT WHAT PROFIT IS
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TODAY AS WE
IN COMING MONTHS PONDER HOW TO
CONDUCT ELECTED COMING OUT
MONDAY DEPEND DEMOCRATS
CURRENTLY FACE. CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST NUMBER OF
NATIVE AMERICANS MORE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT
THE VOTE THE PERCENTAGES OF
ELIGIBLE VOTERS CONTINUE TO BE
LOW. AS NOTED BY SOME LIMóN
RAMOS NATIVE AMERICAN VOTING
RIGHTS HAVE A LONG AND STORIED
PAST UNFORTUNATELY VOTER
SUPPRESSION DISENFRANCHISEMENT
CONTINUES TO DATE. ONLY TWO
YEARS AGO THE SUPREME COURT
THAT FAN NORTH DAKOTA SPEAK
VOTER ID LAW YOU GET HARDER FOR
STATE RESIDENTS WITHOUT A HOME
ADDRESS THEIR BALLOT. THAT LAW
IN A RULING REJECTED A
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
MADE THEIR LIVING ON RIVER READ
THE BECAUSE THE US POSTAL
SERVICE DOESN'T PROVIDE
RESIDENT TO MAIL THEM IN THERE
AND TRIED TO HAVE ONLY THOUGHT.
TWENTY FOURTEEN IS A GOOD STEP
TO ADDRESS THE LOW NATIVE
AMERICAN TURNED OUT IN
CALIFORNIA AND NOTED THAT HE
WENT TO NATION STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THE GUIDANCE THAT THE
GUIDE THE RECOMMENDATION. WILL
RESULT IN THE WORK. WE'LL HAVE
TO WAIT VOTER TURNOUT WE ARE
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MS OTHER ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SOME OF THE BILL
WE'RE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM. IF SO PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND. I DON'T SEE
ANY. THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU'D LIKE YOU UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO WE DO
HAVE A COMMENT FROM LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEYER ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. GREAT. MODERATOR IS
THERE. ANYONE ELSE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR YOU SAID NO THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THE
COMMITTEE DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
LETTERS OF OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO WE DO NOT HAVE A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
IF THERE IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN. SEEING NONE. PHONE
LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION BABY
TWENTY THREE FOURTEEN MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY THREE
FOURTEEN. AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND A ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE'S NO ONE IN KILL.
BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
THIS SOME MUCH NEEDED BILL FOR-
NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION THE
VOTING RIGHTS THAT ARE THERE IN
A CHANCE TO START TO MOVE
FORWARD PAST THE STATE TOWARD
PASSPORTS CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AT
THIS TIME I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WOULD ENJOY ANY
CALL AUTHORS IT WOULD LIKE TO
ADD ON TO THIS BILL. RATE THE
THING OFFER AUTHOR IRVING ON
OUR COMMITTEE TODAY IN FOR
OFFERING. THIS COMMONSENSE BILL
AS THE AUTHOR HAS POINTED OUT
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES. THE
PARTICIPATING IN OUR ELECTORAL
PROCESS. THE ACT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED THAT THE CHANCE-
TWICE- IN SOUTH DAKOTA AND
MONTANA- TO WORK. WITH NATIVE
AMERICAN RESERVATIONS ON. BOTH
GETTING. DOUG PEOPLE TO VOTE
AND ALSO VOTER PROTECTION. ON
U. S. SENATE RACES IN A TWO
AND- IN TWO THOUSAND SIX- TO
REALLY APPRECIATE- THIS WORK I
THINK IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR CALIFORNIA. THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PROPOSED BY THIS BILL
I'D FORGOTTEN THAT UNTIL. YOUR
CONDITION THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PROPOSED BY THIS BILL
WILL BRING RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO
IDENTIFY THOSE CHALLENGES. AND
TO ESTABLISH RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR ELIMINATING BARRIERS TO
VOTER PARTICIPATION. BY THE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR
THESE VERY RECORD- FOR THESE
REASONS I RECOMMEND SUPPORT AT
ALSO BE HAPPY TO. BE ADDED ON
AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU OF THE
BILL ON AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION. THANK THANK YOU THE
REST THERE. WHEN WE GOT SUITE
ALL RIGHT WE GOT A- THANK YOU
SO MUCH- WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
BERMAN I BERMAN HI. GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER HI RAMOS HI RAMOS HI
LOW. MAYES HI MAYES AYE MULLIN
MULLIN I WEBER. FIVE ZERO GREAT
CONGRATULATIONS MR ALMOST THAT
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
UNLESS YOU OF I SURE GALLAGHER
BEFORE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM
LET'S TAKE OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THERE ARE TWO BILLS TO
HAVE AN OCEAN VIEW EMOTION A
MAN A SECOND THEIR TWO BILLS ON
THE CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE BY SOME
NUMBER GALLAGHER AND ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB THIRTY THREE
SEVENTY BY THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE DOES ANY MEMBER WITH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IT DO WE HAVE WE
HAVE A MOTION- AND A SECOND.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BERMAN ACT BERMAN I
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I RAMOS
RAMOS I LOW. MAYES MAYES AYE
MULLIN MULLIN HI WEBER. FIVE
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT FIVE TWO ZERO WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WHO I THINK ARE STILL IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE JUST
TAKING LONGER THAN THAT OKAY-
TO. THE NEXT BILL TO BE
PRESENTED IT WILL BE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK. AS I PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN IT WILL BE PRESENTING
THAT BILL AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK WILL BE JOINING US BY
PHONE FOR THAT PRESENTATION.
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF OR IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE CALL AND NOW.
AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC CALL
IN NUMBER. FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER LOWE FOR JOINING US
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR LIMEY TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF DOCTOR QUIRK AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNTER WILL ENCOURAGE COUNTIES
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE EXISTING
RISK LIMITING AUDIT PILOT
PROGRAM. ELECTION ON ITS PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN ENSURING
ACCURATE ELECTION RESULTS IN
PUBLIC TRUST ELECTION OUTCOMES
THE R. L. A PILOT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
PERMITS ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
CONDUCT AN ARE LA IN PLACE OF A
1% MANUAL TALLY. CURRENTLY
COUNTIES WHICH DISSIPATE IN THE
ARE LA PILOT PROGRAM HAVE TO
USE OUR LA ON ALL THE CONTESTS
IN A JURISDICTION. COUNTIES ARE
RELUCTANT TO USE THE NEW
TECHNIQUE ON ALL OF THEIR
CONTESTS AB TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
WILL REMOVE THE ALL OR NOTHING
REQUIREMENT BERRIER CLARIFY
THAT COUNTIES ARE PERMITTED TO
CONDUCT RISK LIMITING AUDITS IN
LIEU OF OR IN ADDITION TO. THE
1% ANNUAL TALLY ON ANY AMOUNT
OF ELECTION CONTEST THIS
MEASURE WILL ALSO REMOVE THE
CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. IN THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED
CONFIDENCE ELECTION RESULTS AS
THE CURRENT 1% MANUAL TALLY THE
URGENCY CALL US IN THE BILL
WERE INSURER COUNTIES ARE ABLE
TO USE OUR ALLIES. ARE LA FOR
SYNC CONTEST THIS NOVEMBER. AND
TEST BANKRUPT VIDEO ROOM IN THE
CAPITOL OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL ARE ROBERT AVALON
AND RUSHED OFF A FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN LET'S MOVE ON TO
SOMETHING MEMBER BILL QUIRK ON
THE PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBER
QUIRK IF YOU'RE THERE YOU MAY
PERCEIVE. OUR IT. THE QUIRK. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR AND
MISTER MOLLEN- THE BILL WILL
HELP MODERNIZE THE ELECTION
AUDITING PROCESS AND ENCOURAGE
THE USE OF RITALIN MEDIAN AUDIT.
COUNTY MEET THIS FLEXIBILITY
DECIDE WHICH CONTEST THEY WOULD
LIKE TO CONDUCT THE ON THE ON
THE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED WILL
PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL CHANGES
NECESSARY TO ALLOW COUNTY
IMPLEMENTED SUFFICIENT TYPE OF
ELECTION AUDIT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US BY PHONE AS A MEMBER QUIRK.
NOW LET'S MOVE O TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESS WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AS A REMINDER EACH FARMER WHEN
THIS IS UP TO THREE MINUTES TO
PRESENT YOUR TESTIMONY. YOUR
ENCOURAGE HOWEVER TO KEEP YOUR
REMARKS BRIEF AND TO REFRAIN
FROM TESTIMONY THAT IS
DUPLICATIVE O TESTIMONY FROM
OTHER WITNESSES. ARE FOR FORMER
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS ROBERT AVALON FROM THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE-
EXPEDIA. WHO IN A BIT OF MAGIC
IS NOW IN THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. MR HAVEL ON IT
YOU MAY PROCEED. RIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS-
MY NAME IS ROBERT AVALON DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF STATE FOR POLICY
AND PLANNING ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY OF STATE OUT EXPEDIA
WE'RE SPONSORING AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND ARE WORKING WITH
THE SENATE OVER QUIRK AND HIS
OFFICE ON THIS BILL TO HIS
AUTHORSHIP FOR. AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE REGARDING RISK
LIMITING AUDITS BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THIS BILL
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY AND ALLOWS
COUNTIES TO DO OUR LAYS BY
ALLOWING COUNTIES TO SELECT ONE
OR MORE RACES INSTEAD OF THE
CURRENT LAN PLACE WHICH
REQUIRES. COUNTY TO DO ARE
ALWAYS FOR ALL CONTESTS THAT
THEY WISH AND CHOOSE TO DO SO-
HERE WITH ME IS RUSHED OFF ON
BEHALF OF OUR AGENCY- ROGERS
BEEN A LEAD STAFF MEMBER ON
THIS ISSUE AND IS HERE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS WELL.
SO MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER REBEL.
IN THE SECOND PRIMARY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS- RUNS
BE YOUR BALL FOUGHT. FROM THE
OFFICE OF SECRETARY OF STATE US
BUT YEAH WHO IS ALSO. WITH THIS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. I
UNDERSTAND THAT MY MISTER BALL
FLIES HERE PRIMARILY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS MAY HAVE
ON THIS BILL IS THAT CORRECT.
YES THE SHIP GREAT THE FEEL
FREE IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS. THE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SO I'LL BE BRIEF- BUT THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
IMPLEMENT THE INTENT BEHIND THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BILL
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE THAT WAS
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR ALL THE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA TO TEST
THE RISK LOSING AUDIT PLOT
PROGRAM. AND PROVIDE A VALUABLE
EXPERIENCE TO IMPROVE THE
TRUSTWORTHINESS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTION AND TO
INFORM FUTURE AUDIT
LEGISLATION. THIS BILL BY
PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY AS TO THE
COUNTIES TO SELECT THE CONTEST
AND BY REMOVING THE CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL CONTEST FROM THE
EQUATION AND BY EXTENDING THE
TIME OF THE PILOT PROGRAM TO
INCLUDE THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION IS DOING
EXACTLY THE SAME. AND WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU MISTER BOPHA. ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WHO ARE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM THERE SO PLEASE YOUR HAND.
SEEING NONE. PHONE LINES ARE
NOW OPEN FOR A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED. AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
COMING UP PLEASE BEAR WITH OF.
THANK YOU. ARE WE DO GO TO LINE
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SORRY ABOUT THAT MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS RYAN ROCK OVER THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION QUICKEN
LECTURES OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE KNOWN
FOR THEIR IN Q. GREAT. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THE
COMMITTEE DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
COMMUNICATIONS FROM INDIVIDUALS
OR ORGANIZATIONS SEEKING TO
TESTIFY AS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
WHO WITH WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED IF SO PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND SEEING NON. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. NOW IT
SHOULD BE THE PHONE LINES ARE
NOW OPEN FOR WHEN THIS IS
OPPOSITION. AB TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED. WE HAVE NO
ANY KILL THAT'S FANTASTIC. ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING
NONE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
REQUEST FOR ADULT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBERS A
MULLIN AND QUIRK A TAG TEAM IF
THERE EVER WAS ONE- DO WE HAVE
A MOTION BUT I DON'T REMEMBER
WE DID THANK YOU- SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THIS IS
GONNA YOU KNOW WHO DID IT
RATHER WE GOT MISTER MAYES OFF
WITH THE MOTION MR ACOSTA THE
SECOND. I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRING THIS BILL FORWARD THIS
BILL IS THE RESULT OF
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS BETWEEN
THE SECRETARY OF STATE. AND
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS THE
SENSIBLE CHANGE PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL WILL MAKE IT MORE
FEASIBLE FOR COUNTIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE RISK LIMIT.
I'M THIS BILL WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MRS SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON AB
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND BE RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
HI. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER HI
RAMOS RAMOS I LOW. LOW HI MAYES
MAYES I MULLIN MULLIN HI WEBER.
WEBER HI SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS- MISTER QUIRK
MISTER MULLIN THAT BILL IS AT
SEVEN ZERO THAT CONCLUDES THE
ITEMS ON THE COMMITTEE'S AGENDA
FOR TODAY BEFORE WE CAN ADJOURN
WE NEED TO SPEND TO SOME BILLS
THAT ARE ON CALL MEMBERS. WHO
GOT HERE AFTER WE STARTED
PLEASE REMAIN IN YOUR SEATS ALL
GO THROUGH THE ROLE FOR ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA- MISTER SECRETARY
WILL YOU OPEN THE ROLE AND FOR
OUR NEW MEMBERS HERE- EVERYONE
ELSE SO FAR HAS JOINED AS A CO
AUTHOR ON MR ALMOST THIS BILL.
IF ANYONE ELSE'S OWN CLOUT. ON
AB TWO THREE ONE FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS THE
CURRENT VOTE AS FIVE TO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI LOW.
LOW HI WEBER. WEBER HI. COOL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IF SIMPLY NO PRESSURE. GREAT
AND THE FAMILY AFFAIR WAS ROLES
SO WITH THAT- CAN WE HELP YOU
CAN SEND GALLAGHER THANK THEIR
MIND I WAS JUST GETTING TO THAT.
AND ON THE CAN AM CALENDAR THE
CURTAIN VOTE AS FIVE TO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I LOW.
LOW HI WEBER WEBER HI THAT'S
SEVEN ZERO THAT IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO AND WITH THAT WE ARE DONE
THANK YOU.